hey folks is peter brown with a gamespot
news update apparently the Wall Street
Journal is reporting that Netflix is in
deals of the Nintendo to develop a
live-action Legend of Zelda series what
a story posted in the Wall Street
Journal states Netflix is in the early
stages of developing a live-action
series based on Zelda but an ordinary
boy named link who must rescue a
princess named Zelda and save a fantasy
world called Hyrule duh according to an
unnamed source Netflix is working
closely with Nintendo to develop the
series while the no writer is currently
attached to it Netflix has recently
created several high quality critically
acclaimed shows including house of cards
and orange is the new black perhaps
arrested development is a better
comparison because just like that series
if they [ __ ] up the Zelda series they're
gonna have some pissed-off fans to deal
with and the last arrested development
season was ok there is no guarantee that
this show will actually materialize
there were talks of a new Mario movie
that never came through although if it
does what type of show would you like to
see a darker more serious Game of
Thrones style show or a more
lighthearted show with a pixar style
sense of humor if I think about the
number of link quotes wait no link
doesn't talk at all how is that gonna
work in the form of a TV series well
excuse me princess more updates on this
announcement stay tuned to gamespot com
/ news
you